let's go next to our caller from the
nine five one area code who's calling
today from 951 and where are you calling
from all right Lisa what's on your mind
today okay I wanted to address the issue
of the census and the new question about
citizenship yes um this was a topic that
interested me very much during our last
census in 2010 and I did a lot of
research on it and the fact is that the
US Census Bureau is authorized to do a
head count
and that's it all those questions are
voluntary you don't have to answer any
of them that's right and so you know if
somebody doesn't want to answer their
citizenship question they don't have to
so when I filled out my census forms I
didn't even give our names I just gave
them how many people were in my house I
told them RA just as I believe that's
important for the Congress people to
know their you know the their
constituency the you know and also I
gave our income level because you know
they should know what services they need
to provide as far as kids education and
Senior Services and that but all those
other questions I left blank that's
great that you know that but I'm sure
I'm guessing that you so this is an
argument for the citizenship question
shouldn't be on there or is this an
argument for who cares if it's on there
people don't have to answer it right
yeah we do which of the two are you
arguing um the one that that people
don't have to answer it yes no I know
people right but the problem is Lisa
just not everybody is going to hear this
phone call not everybody is going to get
the message about voluntary questions so
the problem is that when you put that
question on there the whole point of it
is that it's going to dissuade certain
people from filling out the census at
all which will mean those populations
are under counted so I completely agree
with you you don't have to answer it but
it's still extremely problematic to
include the question and hopefully the
the
legal action to try to stop it will
succeed well I think we need to get the
word out that people don't need to I
mean the the Census Bureau has no legal
authority to compel anyone yes I agree
we've got to get the word out but you
know there's 340 million people in this
country and most of them are not going
to get that word and certainly not going
to come front and center from the
current administration that's for sure
but you're absolutely right Lisa and I
appreciate you calling in and making
that call on that note let me go to a
break sorry to everybody I didn't get to
we will take live calls again appreciate
you calling it